glad I'm going to come back to you
because you were primarily responsible
for the design of the Beast I believe if
I'm right and it's talked about I mean
you're basically having to create what
in essence was the one of the more
complex characters I think so could you
talk about how you chose to what the
process was of coming up with the
combination of things that made that
that beast character and then also later
the transformation into prints I guess
well that sketchbook that I started
keeping in London was really important
one of the first things I started to
draw were I would walk past the Regents
Park Zoo to good Street in London and
they had these wolves that would walk
pacing back and forth and I just
realized I loved their back legs so I
started just drawing those and and then
they had a a mandrill named Boris there
and I went in and was sketching Boris
and Boris turned around his colorful
rear end and there was this one in
gleesh late-late a minute we'll just
going to a bad place
yeah yeah so I remember the English lady
standing next to me maybe it was you
Angela I don't know she said she said
he's got two rainbow bamyas not to say
that beast well you never saw underneath
the pass there but so I found the zoo
incredibly helpful and there was a
taxidermy place not far from the studio
and so I asked Don if we could buy a
buffalo head and so we had that on my
wall and then a wild boar head on the
wall as well and there was a sadness to
the buffalo head probably because he was
on my wall you know I thought that that
was a good design but I also wanted to
there was a gorilla because beasts has
got this like cranium big cranium and I
wanted to know what it felt like to be
now face to face with 600-pound beast
and so I asked if I could go to the zoo
and I asked if I could actually get in
the cage with this gorilla I don't
remember this because yeah my expense
report looked really weird that way
bison head so I I drew this this gorilla
named Caesar there who wasn't happy that
I they wouldn't let me in the cage
actually because Caesar had done
something wrong and they kept him down
below in this dark cage and it was kind
of sad and and I went down there and you
couldn't quite see it was really dark
really dark and I'm looking at all you
can see with these shiny beasts eyes ah
and so he was slowly coming out of the
dark and it was exactly like beast in
the movie and he didn't want me there
and I saw him reach down and grab a
handful of gorilla poo I was like whoa
so I got out of there before that
happened one last really quick thing
here but I didn't know all of this was
coming together and but it's not just
the design it's the voice and Kirk and
Gary had given me a cassette with a
whole series of different actors voices
and they said just listen to this I'm
we're not going to tell you anything
about who did what voice or any of these
things because some of them were names
that I would know so I was just doing
dishes that night listening to this and
you know there was a kind of a wild
beast and there was different beast
voices and then there was this
conflicted warm tender but deep voice
and it was like I could I mean I could
just that's it I you recognize that that
that was
that was the Beast and and I came back
in I said it's it's got to be this one
and you guys said yeah well that's
that's Robbie Benson Wow so Robbie when
I was starting in my own show business
career as a projectionist
I ran Jeremy and so from that point on I
was like who is this guy
so I've been falling but I got to tell
you after maybe I was purchased but
Jeremy is not the guy I expected to be
the Beast in Beauty and the Beast so
could you talk about how you got the
addition and how how you you know what
was your key and what did you how did
you see that character and what what do
you think it was I mean Glen has told us
a little bit but what were you going for
I think when I read the sides
I could tell immediately that it wasn't
like anything that I had ever gone up
for as far as animation it definitely
did read like a Broadway show and and I
never thought of the character of beast
as and as a cartoon I mean that's like a
bad word it's you know Watson it's not a
cartoon thanks to you it's like amazing
and um you know I I don't know I I went
in for the initial audition and I was
kind of shocked because it's Disney and
there were two people in the room and
there was a Walkman I thought wow that's
odd
I mean we're you know animation Disney
voice a Walkman
and then because I've always written
songs and I've always engineered my own
stuff I looked at the Walkman and
thought okay so there's two things going
on here that really could work one play
it honestly and I kind of was typecast
for the part of the beast um I'm so
sorry Carla
we've been married thirty four years um
so the first thing is I wanted to play
it honestly and and I I knew I could do
that um but then as a sound engineer I'm
looking at this Walkman and I'm thinking
wow how many poor guys have walked in
here and gone oh and then tape you know
a little compression on those little
condenser mics so their room sounds like
ah and so I just take the thing go down
are you happy here with me and you know
and if you play it if you if you play it
from your heart and obviously understand
the technology which I was really lucky
I finally got a job